Чеченська діаспора Німеччини вийшла
на акцію протесту вже вдруге за останній тиждень.
Привід - холоднокровне вбивство в Берліні 23 серпня.
Жертва - 40-річний Зелімхан Хангошвілі,
громадянин Грузії чеченського походження,
колишній польовий командир часів другої чеченської війни,
імовірний радник грузинських та українських силовиків.
Росія розшукувала його за тероризм.
Два роки тому Хангошвілі через Україну приїхав до Німеччини
і попросив політичного притулку.
Берлін йому відмовив, а останнім часом розглядав апеляцію.
- Чеченцям дуже часто відмовляють,
і Зелімхан Хангошвілі - один із яскравих прикладів цієї ситуації.
Це людина, на яку було кілька замахів за межами Німеччини.
Він приїхав сюди, але не отримав захисту від німецької влади.
Убивство сталося в самісінькому центрі німецької столиці -
в парку Малий Тірґартен, на очах у свідків,
неподалік офісу федеральної канцлерки Анґели Меркель
та в пішій досяжності до Рейхстагу.
Кілька пострілів у спину, контрольний у голову,
велосипед і зброю - в річку, після чого -
невдала спроба втекти на електросамокаті -
ось подробиці вбивства, яке чеченська діаспора називає замовним.
Організатором чеченська діаспора вважає російську владу,
а метою цього злочину - показати силу
та здатність Кремля будь-де дістати своїх критиків.
Німецькі ЗМІ пишуть про паралелі зі справою Скрипаля
та можливий дипломатичний скандал між Німеччиною і Росією.
Британець Марк Галеотті, якого вважають фахівцем
щодо російських спецслужб, теж переконаний:
убивця діяв на замовлення з Росії.
- Можна припустити, що він - співробітник або найманець,
який діє в інтересах однієї з російських спецслужб.
У зв'язку з цим згадують військову розвідку ГРУ,
яку звинувачують у спробі вбивства Скрипаля.
Але в цьому випадку це поки не точно.
Всі російські спецслужби час від часу займаються
тим, що вони самі називають "мокрими справами",
тобто вбивствами. Я не здивуюся, якщо
цей персонаж працював на ФСБ -
найпотужнішу російську спецслужбу, яка переважно
відповідає за внутрішню безпеку і, зокрема, курирує чеченців.
Журналісти видань Insider, Bellingcat та Spiegel,
провели своє власне спільне розслідування обставин убивства.
Вони з’ясували: ймовірний убивця
приїхав у Німеччину з підробним паспортом,
бо Вадима Соколова 1970 року народження
з таким номером паспорта, який мешкає
на неіснуючій вулиці в Петербурзі,
немає в жодній російській базі даних.
Журналісти вважають: без допомоги російської влади
людина, відсутня в системі "Роспаспорт",
не пройшла б контроль на кордоні РФ.
За інформацією Spiegel Online, номер паспорта
ймовірного злочинця вказує
на його зв’язок із російськими спецслужбами.
Як стверджують розслідувачі,
цей номер паспорта веде до підрозділу
в міністерстві внутрішніх справ РФ, яке раніше вже
оформлювало документи для співробітників
російської військової розвідки ГРУ.
Відомо, що злочинець мав намір
виїхати з Німеччини одразу після вбивства,
однак поки слідство не повідомляє, які саме докази
вже вдалося зібрати,
а обережні представники уряду Німеччини
утримуються від коментарів щодо політичного підґрунтя вбивства.
- Уряд Німеччини вкрай зацікавлений
у детальному розслідуванні цієї справи,
але все ж я повинен переадресувати
ваше запитання регіональним слідчим органам Берліна.
На мітинг у Берліні прийшов і один із синів убитого.
- Важко. Дуже важко. Зараз теж, не знаю, як сказати,
дуже важко. Складно уявити.
Не можу зараз повірити, що в мене більше немає батька.
Як пише видання Politico,
це перший подібний інцидент, який
стався на німецькій території після холодної війни,
а сама справа змушує згадати про отруєння
російського шпигуна Сергія Скрипаля в Солсбері
та низку інших убивств ворогів Кремля.
На думку Politico, Москва не залишає Берліну
іншого вибору, як зайняти жорсткішу позицію щодо дій Кремля.